[Music]
all right Howard Doss we are still here
at crime con 2022. uh it's been fun this
has been a good time here in Vegas uh
again a hell of a lot bigger than I
expected first time at one of these
these type of deals everybody has been
fantastic we've crossed paths with a lot
of uh you know huge fans of the whole
crime genre and the the podcasters and
television and so forth they know about
more about crime than you do yeah that's
actually there's probably quite a few
that they think they do so there's a lot
of home uh you know home detectives that
are doing their little thing trying to
solve some cases but hey we'll take all
the help we can we got a great guest
today man we do have a great guest today
uh we've got uh the one and only Chris
Hanson here with us hey guys I'm very
very uh honored to have you here with us
been in TV a hell of a long time and
we'll kind of jump through that story
and obviously well known for you know uh
here have a seed and to catch a predator
and all this type of stuff and talk
about what you're doing nowadays
absolutely but uh Chris here on
cocktails and Cocktails we do have a
nice nice drink every episode so as you
should as we should so we are we're
still sipping on our bottle for uh
National barrel company or cocktails and
Cocktails bottle and actually Mike Heinz
one of the owners of cocktail I'm sorry
one of the owners of national barrel
company is literally on a flight in
right now to come hang out with us here
yeah he gave us tonight so
um cheers to you being on here with us I
know you're not having a cocktail but
thank you but uh you guys go ahead
but you're a second journalist and by
far our most famous journalist that
we've had only in my own mind and the
tallest one listen I'm going to say this
well we saw you today walking around uh
you it's something I've heard a million
times
excuse me so on live PD I have to sit
down because I am quite a bit taller
than Dan Abrams and so just you know for
the uh the framing of the shot using
some TV terms there I guess I you know I
sit and when I saw you walk in there I
was like man he's a hell of a lot taller
than I expected so yeah you know through
doing the the shows and podcasts or
whatever chit chatted with quite a few
people in TV and a lot of them were a
little bit shorter so it's nice to see
an over uh an over six footer with me
yeah well you got to do that it helps me
to control the situation with the
Predators absolutely yeah Tower a little
bit and look down upon them as you
should okay so how'd you get started in
uh journalism well I grew up about a
mile and a half from where Jimmy Hoffa
was kidnapped in Suburban Detroit and I
was fascinated by the story I was about
14 years old at the time and he used to
ride my bike up there I think crime tape
and FBI agents and local police and
local reporters and network reporters
and I sort of got bit by the bug so a
few years later when I went off to
college at Michigan State I went down to
the College radio station signed up and
I was a reporter so it was your first
case
well I did a lot of rip and reads you
know
in college and then I was trying to get
into the newspaper the campus newspaper
they had nothing open in the news
department so I was actually a sports
writer for a semester and then I got
into commercial radio at wjam Radio you
have that voice yeah oh well you know I
tried he said wjam
j-i-n-j-i-m all right all right
TV and radio and Jim was the son of the
founder Jim gross and they had built
this
facility it was TV and radio but they
had a built-in swimming pool in the
middle of it as you should as you should
which was great as a young radio
reporter with the keys late at night
after being at Max Bar but that story
aside the owner figured well if TV never
works out we can turn this into a
Holiday Inn so you had the pool built
there it was the most amazing story I've
ever heard and and he they no longer own
the uh the station but yeah it was radio
and TV it was great great place to work
is Detroit still home for you now
Detroit we keep a home in Suburban
Detroit and we've got a place in New
York city so we're back and forth so
Suburban like Novi Eight Mile West
Bloomfield okay yeah yeah I was going to
ask about the Eight Mile you know it's
you know Eminem fan what are we talking
here
yeah yeah you're a Pistons guy I am I'm
more follow basketball in the New York
area
[Music]
recently
um but I keep track of my Pistons yeah I
used to when I was a reporter in Detroit
those guys the bad boys were all around
my age and so they were running around
at the same time some of the baseball
players Kirk Gibson and so much for them
my Posse would run into their Posse it
was a fun time to be in Detroit and in
Detroit you don't have Hollywood
necessarily you don't have Broadway so
the the TV news guys and the sports guys
are the celebrities and so you get a
little bit of clock that way and it was
a fun crew to sort of you run around
with a little bit back in the day yeah a
little bit different era basketball
Anchorman when you say that you know the
Rivalry of the Posse you know yeah
that's the second best yeah exactly well
obviously everybody you know you're well
known for your the The Catch a Predator
I mean I know been in television done a
lot of other different Pro projects and
Howard and I were kind of talking before
you walked in here and I'm not gonna lie
did very little to no research ahead of
time just thought we did you know chit
chat here I know you've had to say this
stuff a million times but just how did
that project come about as far as from
you you know the TV side of getting
involved with the organization that was
working I learned of uh the group
perverted Justice which the time was an
online Watchdog group of volunteers who
would pose his children in chat rooms
and if an adult
approached them agreed to meet them to
have sex they would post that person's
identity the best they had it on their
website and so you could go to
pervertedjustice.com and say this bad
guy this Predator tried to have sex with
this with a child or somebody posing as
a child
and then law enforcement took a bit of
an interest in it and prosecuted some of
the cases and I got wind of it and I
pitched it
to the folks at NBC at Dateline not as a
series or anything close to what it
became but merely as a segment on
Dateline and I figured if we could
combine our ability to wire a house with
hidden cameras and microphones and
combine that with perverted Justice's
ability to pose his children online it
might be compelling and so we did it
and we didn't have law enforcement
involved in the first investigation I
had security like Iran United a retired
NYPD lieutenant and we had a house in
Bethpage Long Island and I was driving
out there and I started to think you
know what if nobody shows up what if
I've just wasted tens of thousands of
dollars of the Network's money and with
that my producer called and said where
the hell are you there are two guys
supposed to be here in 45 minutes and by
the end of that two and a half day
investigation we had 17 guys surface
including a New York City firefighter
and I was blown away
the people at the network were blown
away the material was among the most
compelling I had ever captured
and you know I had a great team working
with me on this it wasn't a solo Affair
obviously in in the United States I mean
I had been overseas
and done stuff in Cambodia where we had
infiltrated brothels with Americans and
Western Europeans going there to abuse
children we had done stuff in India with
child slave labor and in other places
around the world but never in the United
States if we ever captured anything so
compelling as this we essentially
infiltrated the commission of a felony
and watched me interview the guy
and try to figure out what the hell they
were doing
and so this material was kind of around
NBC for
you know probably
nine months almost before it aired and
we had it cut into you know a three-part
you know show for Dateline and the the
some of the executives were worried how
do we promote it what do we do and I
finally said look this is how you
promote it there's a guy and I didn't
use I used slightly more delicate
language than this or actually more
indelicate language than this to get my
point across but there's a guy at your
back door who wants to have sex with
your daughter tonight we're going to
show you how to prevent that and it
aired and predictably it got
an amazing response so we did it again
in Washington outside Washington DC and
then the third time
we thought well
we need to collaborate with law
enforcement because it's the socially
responsible thing to do for justice one
two it's amazingly unsatisfying for the
viewer to see these guys leave the sting
house Whistling Dixie and twirling an
umbrella yep these guys got to face
Justice now some of these cases before
we collaborated with law enforcement
were prosecuted successfully the rabbi
many others but we had to change and
what we've done since then is
continually evolve
to
be socially responsible for the sake of
justice and safety of the crew to do the
investigations the way we do them today
and I just did one a month ago in
Michigan that'll be part of the new
series
so you know you've kind of talked about
the NY uh you know nyfd guy you
mentioned a rabbi I know there was a
teacher that was caught up in it and
um you know the first thing you said was
17 guys is that what it was and just two
stings later or two you know operations
later whatever the term is I think I saw
something you guys call like 50 guys 51
in Riverside California yeah it was
stunning and and how many days did that
go on three days three days 51 guys and
that's just guys that showed up let
alone how many they're communicating
with or other ones that are out there
and this is still kind of in the was it
2004 2005 2006. so it was uh Riverside I
mean we're talking 16 years later where
everybody is on the internet on the
phone things like that now in those days
when we started we merely had decoys in
chat rooms on AOL and Yahoo right well
today
we go do an investigation like we did
recently in Michigan
and I've got to really brush up on new
technology to know which social media
platforms are out there and it's not
just
you know the ones you'd suspect we had a
case recently and we're going to delve
into this uh and our new uh crime
streaming Network true blue
a 12 year old was on Instagram
Instagram
and a 26 year old or 28 year old in
Florida was able to groom her and gain
her confidence and then flew up from
Florida got her to climb out of her
parents bedroom window meet her in a
church parking lot took her to a hotel
where he sexually assaulted her she
shows up at a hospital with the
predictable injuries of having sex with
a 12 year old girl they the sheriff's
department Genesee County Sheriff's
Department figures all this out
because they get the tapes
the surveillance tapes from the hotel
the rental car and everything else and
they find the guy
arrest him
and then they figure out that he's done
this other multiple other times in
different states yeah well and that's
the and sorry Howard I mean it's just an
offshoot of something we found
during our predator's day right the same
law enforcement agency happened to have
that going on at around the same time
yeah you know and that's something
Howard and I have talked about him and
we've actually even talked about on a
previous episode he's got a daughter
he's got two daughters I've got a
daughter they're all grown I mean
they're in their early 20s now mid-20s
um but it's those vulnerable kids like
that that are on just as you said social
media platforms now Tick Tock Instagram
Snapchat and it's stuff that's
communicated uh and you know it's not
it's not old school internet anymore you
know let me get your emails or the chat
rooms think about during the pandemic
yeah everybody's in town you know the
the number is reported by the national
Center for missing and exploited
children are absolutely stunning yep the
number of inappropriate contacts
reported and there's mandatory reporting
from Facebook and Tick Tock and you know
Instagram and Snapchat and all that uh
go right to the nickname
and the amount of inappropriate contacts
between adult and children and child
porn transmission between adults and
children shot up like 900 percent during
the pandemic
which terrifies me as a as a father it
terrifies me I mean my kids are grown
sure you know and
but I worry about you know the Next
Generation Well I mean the thing is is
we talk about the Next Generation we
were talked about by the previous
generation as the Next Generation
absolutely not bad or but now think
about this Predator has spanned three
generations right you know one of my
favorite tweets ever was a guy talking
about you know who Chris Hansen is and
he said I was sitting in a room with my
76 year old Dad I'm 40 and my kids you
know 15 and I asked him he said oh the
guy the the dad says oh the guy who
catches creeps and the the 15 year old
said oh he's the guy on the on the
internet all the time on YouTube with
the Predators right you know it's it's
that's what
we've hit now and I think at the end of
the day besides you know
the value that this material has the
Enterprise reporting and all the things
that we do in terms of taking people
inside the commission of a felony I
think that that my takeaway or what I
try to do is get in the minds of these
guys try to understand it better and
hear the voice of a victim and create
this dialogue and awareness that maybe
didn't exist before and that's really
what this is all about I mean we want to
take the viewer and you guys know this
from from this podcast and from your
time in TV with Dan and all that you
want to take the viewer
on a journey of Discovery absolutely and
and you know and that's the thing about
I think with The Predator franchise did
was open my eyes at least to how we do
Enterprise reporting it's not
traditional investigative reporting
where you're getting reams of documents
all that you're you're you're it's in
the moment you're sticking your neck out
in the moment
and one of the things I have so much fun
with on my podcast Predators I've called
is I get to go back into these cases and
really immerse myself in them and then
tell the story
of what this guy did who he was what he
had accomplished afterwards and where he
is today and it resonates with people
because we don't have time in the moment
you guys know that sure sure I'm
watching his hands uh yeah I've got the
transcripts I may know what he does for
a living but I may not the cop a month
ago in Michigan I didn't know he was a
cop yeah I mean I know we talked about
it before we jumped on air and I was
just going to ask you your podcast
Predators I've caught uh obviously
there's a few that stick out you know
despite the uh gosh how many do you know
you were involved with or the show 500
close to 500 so out of 500 it's the same
thing for me as a copper as long as I
was arrested thousands and I mean
literally thousands of people but there
are a handful of either arrests a
handful of bad guys that I've dealt with
just like that dude was fucking
different yeah you know and there's guys
like that stick out so
out of the 500 or this one you recently
I'm actually really interested in the
one just recently if you want to talk
about it I know yeah Todd Barraco
um
police officer
in a small town in mid Michigan Vassar
he walks in
and the way we do the investigations now
is if he walks in and I make the
approach first and I can get him to talk
to me which most of the time is what
happens that's the way I do it when I'm
finished with my talking to him and I'm
involved in terms of watching the chats
and dealing with the the law enforcement
decoys who go online and so I have a
sense of experience who he is what he
wants and sorry to cut you off there
much like cancer Predator was what
you're doing now do you guys still have
a camera crew that's in there so so he
knows if it's the same I mean obviously
everybody you know knows you first yeah
and shockingly after 18 years of doing
it some guys don't even know it's me now
gotcha right so it's because you're tall
they're not they're not expecting a tall
Chris Hanson to walk in yeah yeah his
hair got gray yeah it was crazy
but he comes in
pulls in his you know new pickup truck
and he marches in and I've talked to the
male on-site decoy so there's a guy
there who's you know like a police cadet
who looks younger
and
the the line that he's going to use is
come on in and I left my vape upstairs
something a kid would say something a
kid would say exactly so he comes in was
the first one of that day right and so
the decoy is a little I don't know gave
off maybe a bit of a nervous vibe and so
Bronco
being a cop
gets sketchy and bolts so I don't even I
come around the corner I said hey you
know I'm going to need to talk to you
and he's gone cops grab bring him back
in the scene is secured now I get a shot
to interview him now if he
talks to me great if he doesn't well
these gentlemen over here would like to
speak to you and I step to the side
so he's getting shitty with me I mean
he's just indignant and he's turning
around and turn those cameras off and
ordering me
what to do I said look you're not
running the show here
and there's cameras over here cameras
over here and cameras over here and now
the big camera's come out
and I'm Adam and he says you don't know
I didn't do anything wrong I said I've
got the chat right here and I read the
chat back and then I take the tube of
lubricant which he brought with him and
I put her on his face but what's this
[Music]
off he goes he leaves and I say to the
crew I said that's going to be a cop
you know a school administer somebody in
a position of authority as I mentioned
earlier and um they taught us kind of
our three loaded guns his creds and
handcuffs and now people are coming out
of the woodwork to me
about stuff he's done before why he was
fired from a previous
uh agency agency he was also a school
administrator in charge of kids he was
um
um accused I had the city
uh the town supervisor of a small town
say that he went to her home and
harassed her because she fired him and
when she drove through the town where he
was a cop until he was busted he pulled
her over
and wrote her 30 over which would be
reckless driving and and just to jam her
up
and so you've got this this is like one
of those movies about the Rogue Bad Evil
cop right and this thing will become a
segment of its own at some point just
the nightmare for society basically
someone in position as Authority that's
a predator not that he had interviewed
you know at a larger Department
in Oakland County Sheriff's Department
which is run by you know Sheriff who
went to the same high school I went to
you know I grew up in that area so you
know it's hard to pick a major law
enforcement agency where I don't know
people of course
and and they flagged them
you know she's had too many different
jobs here this is there's a reason so
let's back this up a little bit what was
the the cadet you had there how old was
he posing as he was posing as 14 15 14
about to turn 15. and how did he
approach him what was it on Instagram
this was on a social media uh you know
platform
um I think this might have been kick or
maybe grinder or something like that and
and you're supposed to be 18 to go on
but kids go on it and they say look I'm
only this and they make it very clear
and then there's a discussion in the
chat about are your parents home and are
you sure this is okay and do you like
bottom or top and you know yeah I smell
good you know do you shave you know the
usual stuff and and so he it was clear
in the chat
you know and as you know is a Lawman
you know in Most states the crime is
committed with the solicitation online
absolutely moving up is you know icing
on the cake right the TV part that's
when you get him in custody in Most
states the solicitation is in the chat
logs
and that's the case so let's finish this
up where's the where was this guy
charged with he was charged with two or
three counts related to solicitation of
a minor for sex using
um the internet uh for uh you know
lewdness of his behavior and he
immediately you know the sheriff's
department that arrested him got him
held unveil some of these guys get out
of their own recognization right quickly
and he was held overnight he finally
made bond and he was
suspended that day
the sheriff in Genesee County Chris
Swanson is very proactive his ghost team
the Genesee human oppression Strike Team
is well into the hundreds in terms of
guys they've arrested and we cross paths
he was one of the sheriffs during the
black lives matter protests in and
around Flint Michigan who
defused it without violence he got
attention worldwide because he was on a
on a vehicle and took his helmet off and
walked Walked Out There I do remember
that situation he was on everywhere so I
had him on my YouTube show I have a seat
with Chris Hansen to talk about that and
you know at the time I was gearing up to
do more Predator stuff so he was one of
the law enforcement officials who I'm
now working with on these new Predator
operations Chris when you're talking
about you know you guys used a male
right there on that deal and going even
back to catch or Predator did you guys
just kind of play with both using both
male and females you know that were
decoys at that age it's
it's you know it's easier to do the
online decoy work because you know you
have a picture that you use or have
pictures that you use and
it can be anybody it could be a 50 year
old man or woman doing the
typing right right but you need somebody
there now in the early investigations
Dell Harvey of perverted Justice would
Poise as oppose as a boy or a girl there
wouldn't be that face-to-face
interaction she would you know say hey
I'm upstairs hey I just done my toe hey
I'm getting the laundry hey I'm getting
the sweet tea come on in excuse was come
on in and I pop in pretty quickly later
we were able to find on-site decoys who
were of age but looked younger who were
perhaps theater students at a nearby
College in one case the daughter of the
home's owner the home we rented for the
sting and they got really good at it
yeah and so what you do is you capture
the moment of
conversation between the predator and
this live girl or boy and you see
this grooming process go down in real
time and it's chilling oh very much so
you know sometimes they they freak and
then I gotta I have to come in and take
your business but but we've had some of
these things
run for a while and and some of these
young people were very very good at
doing it and it's a little dicey for us
because I mean you know law
enforcement's outside doing their thing
and they'd bail us out if they had to we
had Security on the inside watching but
we had a couple cases that they a couple
weeks ago we did the case of a guy who
was a washout as a cop but he had a gun
with him we had a guy in in an
investigation just five years ago
um he was through the police academy
waiting for a job and he had a loaded
gun in his car there for a 13 year old
girl so you know we make them go through
procedure to make us as comfortable as
possible is is to the fact that not
bringing a gun in the house sure because
we won't risk that
the police can arrest him outside and we
can deal with it later and tell the
story and that's why we try to get video
of the police interrogation as well
because that's obviously very telling
very telling yeah yeah well and just you
know uh back when doing policing earlier
in my career we had we had a couple
areas with within Tulsa that were kind
of known for uh same thing ludax it was
primarily homosexual uh public acts that
were happening and so one of them was
out by our zoo and people from the
public that are going out to the zoo the
park that's out there would see these
things happening so we were asked to go
out there and work undercover in it and
just again going back to catching police
officer who caught a rabbi a teacher
sure firemen and between that 500
there's countless different jobs but uh
you know we had caught guys that were on
their work break married and you know
and it's us as male police officers
posing as other males adults out there
not kids but we legit uh legitimately
had a guy that was a and I don't even
know I didn't even know they still
existed but a Bible say salesman one day
and had a car out there and I swear
cases
cases of Bibles in his car that was out
there and we caught like I said the wide
range of different guys you know a guy
who was a uh he was a guy from Oklahoma
City
um in his 70s that had come down there
to you know see his grandson and just
showed up before he went to go visit his
son decided to come out there and it is
amazing the wide range of predators
corrections officer prison guard who was
on his way to Home Depot to get paint to
paint the house who popped in for a
teenage girl with his wife and children
at home
he's in a very good at home improvements
no no okay so I've got two questions
sure
um females you ever have any female
Predators not ever one who showed up and
um the experts the therapists tell us
that that's because in the case of a
female predator you're more likely to
see the teachers student scenario the
female predator doesn't like the
anonymity where the male Predator gets
off on it got some cases so no we never
say I know it's happened I wrote about
it in my book a case where it was going
on but generally speaking and
specifically in anything we've done
we've not seen it well then my follow-up
question of that is
yeah you've caught the stupid Predators
right obviously the ones that are driven
by that like
that basil emotion that I have to do
this I'm going to go through
I'm a little bit more worried about the
people you don't catch the people that
and how many people would you say that
get spooked
well I think
and this isn't uh firm statistic but I
would venture to say that as many
as have been caught
don't show up for whatever reason they
suspect it's a sting they have a change
of heart
they get nervous or in some cases
they're just trying to get off by having
this conversation and having their
Fantasy online that's what I was just
going to say I guarantee there's a bunch
that are just back they're getting
themselves off excited yeah masturbating
there's some and they have no intention
of showing yeah they'll never do it all
the solicitation is there of a minor has
been committed and so in many of these
cases there are follow-up investigations
we had a guy in the Fairfield
Connecticut investigation
who drove by
inflate and he went away well they
pulled him over traffic stopped and in
his pocket they found a hotel Key and it
was near the sting house in Fairfield
and they get to the hotel and he had a
whole set up there video camera tripod
computer he was going to make a film
with this underage girl
and so the level of this we can we can
all agree this any of this is fucking
awful yeah absolutely but then there's
levels to this like Dante's Inferno of
shit bag right so you have the guys that
are just like oh my God it's I get I get
off by doing this then there's the guys
that like you said that want to produce
some sort of
porn to put out and then there's the who
I think are the worst the ones that like
deal in human trafficking yeah end up
taking these kids and end up they live
the rest of their lives and whore or
however long their life goes on those
are I mean shit is terrifying I think to
every parent in the world and you hear
these stories about human trafficking
and I can guarantee you that as we sit
here in Las Vegas with the NFL draft
going on down the street yep uh and so
many other things happening every
weekend in Vegas that there is human
trafficking absolutely within uh
baseball's throw of where we sit
recording this podcast you should have
said football's through a football store
actually yeah that would have worked
good quarterback probably that's a
better analogy huh because there's no
baseball team here no baseball team here
they do have the Las Vegas Raiders which
just sounds so weird some of Bay Area
guy originally so it's like the Oakland
Raiders to me is always the team or I
mean I wasn't a Raiders fan but it's
just Oakland you know the dirty gritty
Oakland Raiders and then they're down in
Los Angeles where nobody showed up to
watch him and now they're here and well
their stadium in Oakland was it like a
prison dude it was where the Oakland A's
also played baseball so I went to a
million A's ball games there as a kid as
a kid growing up in Detroit did the
Tigers fans played in the same same
thing yeah so it's like you know you got
half a baseball field that's out there
in a football game they're beautiful oh
it's gorgeous Comerica Parks yeah have
you been by this football stadium here
it is yeah I've seen driven past it it
is speaking of stunning yeah let's talk
about stunning we're going to talk about
stunning any uh you know any mail that's
taking care of their uh what their their
their grooming the business the women or
men if that's who their partner is
usually finds them stunning uh this
episode
is brought To Us by manscape
and support for the cocktails and
Cocktails podcast is brought to you by
manscaped I know you're excited about
that Chris
uh they are podcast I understand
absolutely man they're they're the
actually yes bring it on or take it off
right they're the best in men's below
the waist grooming their products are
Precision engineered tools for your
family jewels you don't want any exposed
razor no absolutely not manscape's
performance package uh the ultimate
men's hygiene bundle join over 4 million
almost as many of you cut that you've
caught on uh on on Catch a Predator men
worldwide who trust manscaped with this
exclusive officer our officer offer for
you 20 off and free worldwide shipping
with the code sticks s-t-i-c-k-s at
manscape.com yeah man I actually got the
little the the 4.0 package it comes with
the uh this little lawnmower as they
call it a weed whacker that ear nose and
uh and and and you know your nostrils
your ears so forth get you all pretty
this day and age I mean this is this
yeah this is not run Jeremy from the 70s
so you've got to take care of your
business not 1979. you got to clean it
up
um you know it's also a little
nerve-wracking when you go at yourself
with a little bit of a razor you know
you don't want to Nick yourself no I
mean it's scary it is man there you go
you've got to they're you know got to
take care of it if you keep a flat
stomach honestly you trim it down hey
you know the uh it looks gorgeous yeah
we'll just put it that way pristine got
it be fit to win yeah there you go yeah
if you get that 4.0 package though you
do you get a bunch of stuff they even
throw in a free pair of boxers so wow
can't beat it
deal that's a deal it's like a
post-shave robe yeah yes so anyways back
to as we were talking Chris DNA gotta
get the business done yeah
um man so uh obviously your show was it
was it was kind of groundbreaking
television glad to know you're still
doing it today
um you know listen I I'm sure you've
seen it or at least heard about it the
South Park episode yeah listen so I was
never a South Park Fan uh I just never
watched it I was never into it a story
about that please do because I actually
watched that episode recently it was
when that first year pretty funny how
old are your kids they're now 30 and 28.
and then I have step kids or 22 and 20.
and they're one's about to graduate from
college and one's got one more year but
uh when the South Park episode came out
I was in San Francisco on a unrelated
assignment and one of my agents from
William Morris texted me and says South
Park is doing you tonight it's pretty
funny and I had three hours before I
could see it because of the time change
and 20 minutes later he he sends another
text
it's turned a little dark it's South
Park man and uh so I watched it and I
thought it was funny but my my older
boys at the time were in high school and
they went to high school on the East
Coast with
kids whose dads do a lot of cool stuff
yeah sure they run networks they build
chips and sailing Yachts they're Titans
of Wall Street and so having a dad on
television wasn't necessarily a big deal
but when South Park when you hit South
Park when Chris Hanson was parodied on
South Park that was a big deal suddenly
I was cool and and I look
they make fun but they do it in an
intelligent biting way absolutely they
had absolutely no issue with it one
whatsoever I mean look if if you want to
make fun of me
great if it brings attention to a very
important topic and continues the
dialogue and promotes my work even
better so I have I have very thick skin
and in a business where you expose a lot
of bad guys in an area where there is
the ability to create misinformation
campaigns and attack you back you better
have thick skin in this business sure
let's talk about that episode though
that episode was based on the fact that
you know the details a little bit better
don't you yeah I mean there was a uh an
assistant district attorney if I'm
correct right that was down in Texas
that basically put himself in a position
that he was uh two different chats with
two different decoys online
and he never showed up at the sting
house this is in Murphy Texas he was an
assistant District Attorney At a
neighboring County
and in fact just two weeks ago we did
that episode on the podcast which is we
got a lot of new scoop on that by the
way we'd love to hear it Bill Conrad Jr
and the cops go out to arrest him
the next day as they would anybody else
as it would anybody else now
they were doing this as a courtesy as
opposed to make a big show out of it
arrest him at the DA's office today
right
I had no control over that I would have
preferred television wise they go into
the DA's office the next day because
that's oh that's big on TV absolutely it
wasn't my call so we're in the street
they go in
break down the door he doesn't answer
and they get to the hallway and he's got
a
pistol pointed his head guys I'm not
going to hurt you and he
shoots himself in the head he later dies
there's a helicopter in the backyard
it's it's it's horrible
you never want to see anybody do that
under any circumstances and it's jarring
and it's dark and it's sad for a lot of
reasons but why did he do it
you know ultimately his sister sued NBC
for millions and millions of dollars the
case was settled right
for a lot of different reasons a
settlement comes out of insurance policy
you go to trial which I'm confident we
would have won it comes out of the news
budget it ties up months and months of
my time I'm sad for the sister I truly
am but the reason more likely than than
him worried about Dateline being
involved was that ultimately when they
did the forensic examination of his
laptop they found multiple images of
child porn and in a recent episode of my
podcast Predators I've called with Chris
Hanson we learned from one of the police
officers who then was working for Murphy
that also what was found on their
computer was evidence that helped
convict
Conrad's boss the D.A of that county for
finance Financial mismanagement of the
office and theft of money he ended up
doing Federal time he's the one that got
on TV and criticized everybody involved
in the investigation and you know and
and he then goes to federal prison
for for crimes some of which were
Exposed on Conrad's computer along with
child porn
who's the bad guy there yeah well and
that's the thing you know even and kind
of just to relate that even back to live
PD
um you know some of the stuff it's like
there's people that are doing things
wrong
they get caught but they want to blame
it on the show
right
um you know it's a lack of
accountability for who the actual the
person listen that's a problem in
society in general right now it is but
but you know there's there's an over
correction sometimes absolutely uh and
and you know I don't know the Nuance of
the the details of the the live PD
situation but I I do know that it's it's
it's a great show and I have a lot of
respect for the Dan Abrams and the
people involved in it and go way back
with him to our teams at NBC
but I also know that people can gin up
something
you know you go after a bad guy predator
and we've done this with stories on the
YouTube channel where we've gone after
people who come back at you
and then you take them out of the
digital world and suddenly you're doing
a documentary like the one who did on
this guy Onision
that we did on Discovery plus and you
know you get them back into your ring
and then yeah you know you take care of
business right but it can be unpleasant
until you get used to dealing with these
people and you know these people can gin
up a thousand bots on Twitter and attack
you yep and say whatever the hell they
want about you well and that's going
back to what you're talking about thick
skin you know being a type A personality
I'm a you know a bigger athletic guy uh
a cop so you kind of have that mentality
yes Howard what
go ahead keep time Bring It come on you
know and it's just you know part of the
job I don't want to say you know you
think you're this badass going around
but I mean I I you know I gotta be fit I
can't well I'm out there doing this job
with my belly hanging out over sure sure
not being right but it's to me being
physically fit is also being mentally
aware and sharp and being able to do the
job well and that's how to say exactly
when live PD first started I didn't have
Twitter Twitter television I mean
obviously there's big stories going on
right now about Elon getting a hold of
Twitter and stuff like that but I mean
in the TV world that is huge Twitter is
huge for for how things you know
orchestrate well Twitter was a big part
of live PD where people would you know
send messages in and so forth or comment
during a live show and there were people
that were anti-police that would do so
as well well the timing of it also was
you know when there were obviously it
came after the George Floyd case
horrible policing absolutely right right
no terrible terrible nobody's going to
stand up for that and some other
incidents that took place that did not
reflect well on the police impression
sure you know there's a guy you had a
raid
in in a case where somebody was charged
with creating a danger to the other
people by firing shots but yet not
charged in the death of a woman
resulting from those same shots I mean
come on talk about the Brianna Taylor
stuff yeah that's there's another
there's another podcast episode
and I see
I see it all the time but the the
isolated examples that I see that are so
offensive and there's another one that
that's being investigated now in Grand
Rapids you know you don't have to shoot
the guy in the back of that what are you
thinking right I mean yeah he's a bad
guy he had a bad registration that one I
would kicked it all off for me was that
case in in outside of um
um North Charleston South Carolina
guys running away was that the guy in
the fleet listen that guy that's a
murder he was going a half a mile an
hour yeah
they can trip him you're talking about
the guy that was running he shoots him
from behind well that guy that was a
murder I mean that was a flat out murder
he ran up and even threw his taser if I
remember correctly down next to the guy
to say he had taken my Taser and all
that and I think he got he was convicted
in federal court if I remember correctly
there was just you know those are the
things
that you hate to see used to paint law
enforcement all around the country right
absolutely and I go back and I get it
and I've been criticized for working too
closely with law enforcement for the
Predator case and and there have been
other cases where I've embedded with law
enforcement drug investigations and
things and and I've gotten access that
other reporters didn't get and so I get
I'll take that criticism I open open and
honest criticism is how we improve
journalism in our television projects I
get that transparency but let me go
ahead who else are you going to work
with on that would you work with the PTA
I mean those are the people that need
enforcement that's my point right and
that's why
you know
this true blue digital crime network is
going to be so important because that's
where the Predator stuff is going to go
that's where I'm working on five or six
different documentaries I mean right you
guys ever watch True Detective yeah oh
yeah fantastic I've got the real version
going on right now
in Louisiana right now
I mean the real thing the real deal and
and we have the ability because we've
learned
how to produce television like this more
efficiently
uh a better scale of economics
and faster
where I can be in a lot of different
places in a short period of time and and
and create this content that you won't
see anywhere else and it's branded you
know Chris Hansen blue stuff and take
down and all the rest of it and and so
it's very exciting it's the same thing
that we did with Predator right and and
much like what you guys did with live PD
we
did something in a different way we
infiltrated the commission of a felony
we took people on a journey of discovery
they hear things they wouldn't normally
hear they see things they wouldn't
normally hear and this is the next step
in the evolution of that process in
terms of Distributing that content and
even beyond that it's knowledge sharing
I mean you're sharing people aren't
exposed to this they don't know that
this is a potential weakness that they
have in there and I'm all
or citizen journalists using social
media platforms to to create awareness
yeah but let's do it well but let's do
it well and let's not you know you know
not everybody should be doing this right
exactly and I'm against you know
government
you know supervision of the First
Amendment you can't have it that's why
we have a First Amendment everybody can
do whatever they want but the consumer
needs to be smart right about whether
they're believing some Conspiracy Theory
on YouTube or whether it's a Chris
Hanson branded uh you know show on true
blue or whether it's a you know one of
Dan Abram shows on on your guys networks
I mean it's you have to go with people
who you know and respect and it's it's a
big media world out there and it's
changing but I'm very happy with this
new platform because I think it's going
to revolutionize the way we do business
well I mean from talking to you you're
the amount of Integrity you have towards
this particular cause right human
trafficking yeah
fantastic I mean that's but I also think
you know look you do something for 40
years you start to get the hang of it
right sure sure
you know my 20 years with NBC and local
news before that that allowed me to
create the platform to do the stuff that
I'm doing now where I get to be
an executive producer I get to have
ownership of the content I get to make
decisions that I didn't get to make
before yeah I think that I've earned
that in this business with all the work
and contacts that I've made and I've
seen people here at crime con I ran into
a fellow who was you know ran the
Congressional Affairs office for the FBI
for for 25 years maybe and he was also
the liaison with the press and
just a wonderful wonderful guy who's got
a world of knowledge who's now in
Private Industry I will do something
with him absolutely as you should yeah I
mean and he's here with another former
FBI agent who's written a book and and I
you know it was very difficult
to get the FBI to let you do something
enterprising with them because they're
so worried about the justice department
and I understand they are there's so
much red tape trying to do something
with a federal agency individual uh
pushed and pushed and pushed and got us
a few steps further than where we were
you know it's easier to work with the
sheriff's department because the sheriff
is elected the sheriff makes a decision
is going to do what he believes is right
for the community and for justice
um smaller police departments are
usually easier to do these kind of
Investigations than NYPD or Chicago PD I
mean look I have a lot of friends on
NYPD
John Millers comes from my world
loves the Predator show but we'll never
get that through NYPD now we can do it
in Bethpage Long Island and find people
who come there from NYPD they just
they're not wired that way right it is I
mean they're very good with the media
you know I got my NYPD press pass in my
back I carry it wherever I go but it's
it's not the kind of thing they're going
to do and so you have to be smart about
what area you pick to get the kind of
access you need well Chris Mann honestly
this this has flown by yeah our time is
uh you're here in Vegas you've got money
to go lose and yeah booze to consume and
I've got a question before he leaves
yeah have you ever caught one of these
Predators sat down with them and you're
just you kind of go cold because you
look in their eyes because you have an
incredible EQ I mean you're obviously
able to read people very well yeah have
you ever seen somebody and you're like
oh fuck just a straight up yeah this is
a psychopath there's nothing here yeah I
I I I have and it's it's
it's
somebody typically we've had you know a
number of these guys who has done this
before
you know who has been the bad guy in The
Big Brothers organization and there's a
trail did some prison time and here he
is walking into our sting and the guy is
just a stone cold he might as well have
the word Predator tattooed across his
forehead sure and I'll Jack him around
100 ways till Tuesday and he won't break
and normally I mean
I can usually break about 60 of them
really just get them to lay it all out
there
and some are in purgatory and someplace
in between some are just like the cop we
caught a month ago just you know Fu I'm
not cooperating not happening and so
it's a combination and all those
together
you know make for a pretty damn
compelling piece of content
correct keep doing it keep doing it hey
how can everybody find you get the plug
you give us the YouTube the podcast one
more time YouTube is uh have a seat with
Chris Hanson podcast is Predators I've
called with Chris Hansons on all the
platforms watch trueblue.com for updates
that's the website
um and um official Chris Hanson
Instagram Twitter at Chris Hanson and
there's five Facebook accounts you can
find what about your only fans
well it's very expensive very expensive
well uh all right we'll hit long crime
up for a budget for that so exactly all
right yeah Mr TCAP to you cheers Chris
thanks boys thanks for having me
freaking fantastic
foreign